mi piace in italia benvenuti solite
stories oggi immobili speciale andremo a
fare regali decisi da decidere il nostro
destino decideranno se diventeremo
allora ci sono vari negozi qua nella
lingua del posto che capita dovremo fare
il regalo di natale galà di natale nel
negozio che sorveglierà la rivolta in
più sotto al negozio c'è scritto perfino
ogni casella scegli tu bendato sceglie
l'altro sorpresa quindi dovremo prima
gira anche negozio dovremo comprare il
regalo e poi girare nuovamente per
vedere come in comprarlo certo bendati
se dovremo comprarlo a sorpresa o se
dovrà scegliere l'altra persona ma io ho
provato la todini
questa è una macchietta voglia di gelato
al cioccolato
questo vuol dire che non ti becchi
nessun regalo
[Applauso]
qualsiasi cosa capiterà dovremo farla o
comprare cosa speri che si capiti allora
io voglio
voglio che riesca allora già un
cioccolato chiama subito sorpresa la
mente magari è solo questo come dire che
dobbiamo fare una perfetta quindi che
nessuno saprai cons aprendo poi voglio
da primark delle dei valori e
soprattutto i calzini perché a natale di
milano nei calzini si sa in realtà in
quanto sei piccole si rivelano i calzini
e il regalo più brutto che tu potrai
ricevere poi fai fare da tutti grande è
fatti soprattutto quelli caldi e ferì
catic e latte caldo il biennio sia ai
calzini a natale
similmente non orribile una delle brutte
quelli belli quelle orribili sono quelli
che magari sono troppe troppe
decorazioni troppe cose personali quelli
nerio crisi rue ma noi l'abbiamo
permettono calderai grigie marcolini
quelli decorati devo con una retta sopra
molla è lesionata le dovete usare tutto
l'anno perché mi capiti
primark perché adesso preferito e la
apple
spero di no perché l'altra trovano
magari amazon magari gioco che tiger
però serata dopo che li abbiamo presi di
aprire moschee di questo video e quindi
prendete i pop corn
un bel live se volete vedere altri video
con la ruota così gli astici a
interessanti che potremmo fare con la
ruota carta la barbagia sasso carta
paolini sasso a comicità
intanto vitali stella sono indicate
prima per il negozio e poi vorrei come
come fare il regalo
ho girato però speriamo non sono forse
un altro
[Musica]
ma il primo turno micah p de luca che
bello è la fortuna ha quindi locale
sulla camera piace
[Musica]
apple ora devi rigirare per vedere in
che modalità principio di nuovo ma
allora secondo il rapporto per dato
cosetta vincerà il più forte almeno
fortuna c'era nel primo turno le città
la apple secondo turno la modalità e
imitato benda bilili bellato sulla testa
di tutti contenti a lost altra storia mi
raccomando è che non puoi vedere presi
la cover maldon cavallo ei tifosi
volto di ha fatto belle arti e ora fai
tu questo è il mouse
no non c'è mai stato movendo fermerò a
si no ti stai facendo per cliente
proviamo si muova sistesi abbiamo mai
apparsa una cosa cioè io non so dove
andare ma forse quelli non costano tanto
no niente
se alla fine quindi devi per far salire
ci ritroviamo con e le sue prodotte fa
era un po il mio e anche questo non è
come vedere no condivisi sui doni non mi
sono sbagliato
ora sta nuovamente scendendo giù a sto
scendendo giù
allora spetta fatto tutto soprattutto ma
quanto è lunga e felice che non si fa
niente non so perché i punti proprio
davanti a niente perché tesoro non è
facile con gli occhi chiusi è questo se
un cane però non è la corale cosa si fa
scendendo
ho fatto niente non tifoso ieri di
apportare un po cliccato su sono poi
opzione 12 per 1 a 0 no no io ti posso
dire niente quando arriva lo scoprirai
come ha già fatto sì che ora faccia la
quinta noi e non hanno dato conto è la
non puoi vedere se la sorpresa frezza
basta il mio di co2 qua dobbiamo ancora
girare fatto due volte dove poi vedrai
di dire che ovviamente il regalo
perfetto in via libera riprende dottore
natale o per la befana ormai la primi
commenti spesso l'avete già e se vi è
piaciuto quale parte di questo il più di
tutto dei commenti allora giocava nel
[Musica]
bayern o almeno quindi tiger poi devo
ritirare per vedere come farlo
[Musica]
sceglie l'altro capite quindi ovviamente
non andiamo assolutamente rompi
analizzato però poi apriremo un regalo
stime un buon clima via g piano non pro
il saldo primario che vediamo come sede
di conferenza si soffre gastini doveva
essere scarsi picciaia me allora che non
pregati di sopra e marco bengasi
devo trovare le lettere aveva potuto
scrivere calzini allora purtroppo
supremo anche non si può comprare online
ma io ma non si può comprare online
quindi andremo comunque la primark ma
bendati e che un po difficile a chi
tocca a te la nota
[Musica]
sceglie tutti chiusi
allora in pratica in questo se gli occhi
chiusi devo chiudere gli occhi tu se
vuoi puoi cambiare la posizione della
ruota e dopo puntare in un punto e sarà
il negozio proprio regalo quindi io
chiudo gli occhi di una volta roger
detto lo scotch oggi un'altra anni 70
allora avevo gli occhi puntati vado
fermo però che questo ok poi non so cosa
sia ma dove scegliere la modalità prima
che qualche ora fa sotto gli anti lascia
adito quanti lo faccio direttamente a
una scatola scegli tu sono felice che ha
detto questo sito allora spetta però in
realtà prima tu hai preso una cosa che
necessita di un altra cosa
ho preso ottenere un'ampia c'e stata la
cosa non te lo posso dire però hai preso
una cosa che ha bisogno di un'altra
volta
ok per funzionare al meglio i ragazzi
manca l'ultimo turno meno male un cuore
per ora
allora allora l'ultimo leggere quindi
devo girare io ti ci siamo parlati
spetta ma troppo su con molto cioccolata
di brandire dei regali vorrà 23
il signor nato allora allora aspetta da
questo qua dai bagliori lo ha fatto
cominciate subito si trappole e addosso
a te chi ti piace fare l'esame è un
cambia tono di voce alta i tigers sono
sempre super fastidiosi da prima che si
ci si può far male quindi noi non cambia
tanto la voce quattro livelli
ciao tutto perché stava soffiando sopra
fedeli soffiare devi parlare
[Risate]
ciao ciao ciao a tutti gli davamo il
bambino sta celebrando fischietto
[Musica]
[Risate]
cioccolato cazzata perfetto che con noi
credono alto quindi si sente più un
quesito numero 3 pensate di questo
regalo un regalo mi sembra che fai ma
che era capitato mai perché ormai siamo
dimenticato cosa certa però siccome
quello di aprire vitale anche questi
perché lui era avventato non sa cosa c'è
dentro donna ha fatto vitale che si è
già dimenticato c'era impacchettato e lo
stava già 30 darmi questa cosa mi ha
dato parecchio anche se penso di aver
capito le due reporter e qui già una
buona idea
mi piace si tratta guarda la favo nella
sua che bella xx marzo ma la politica
c'è scritto a cambia cambia l'ora in
pratica con con il liquido con le cose
calde con le bevande calde cambia adesso
è così dice giuro solennemente di non
avere buone intenzioni come la mappa del
malandrino capotte e poi con la bevanda
calda diventa proprio la mappa del
malandrino
bellinzona il prezzo quantistica di
toglierlo passate
forse la scritta nera non ho mai avuto
una tassa che cambia colore ho visto che
sono molto popolari
[Applauso]
sono contento queste due volte una l'ho
scelta io dallo store e in base a quello
che tu hai il prezzo ci sono curioso
troppo spesso una custodia per idea
regalo per tutti e due
puoi aprire prima questo che presento
bendato che se penso che si capisca
oppure questo e quell'altro dai a
scrivere che da anni hai fatto una penna
e una colonna properzio l'anabic blu
quindi sto pensando che questa con terna
qui non lo so se funziona con l'iphone è
sicuramente funziona
[Risate]
addio sa io devo essere benissimo e
regali come rapina insomma la custodia
meravigliosa che bello e contento di
aver fatto questo danno le paga maturo
[Risate]
era stato ciao
allora ti va bè incredibile che bello
però sembra meraviglioso e dai almeno
comunque stiamo editare i video si sente
meno quello però si può in questo video
è già lunghissimo non sono pochi minuti
sapere che quello di prima perché non so
quanto poi taglierò qua sono già otto
minuti quindi facciamo l'unboxing
separato in un altro libro ora vi lascio
poi la casellina qua così potete vederlo
oppure non so se pubblicherò l'indomani
o quando pubblicherò comunque vi lascia
la casa in linea qua qual è il regalo
che mi piace dove di tutti magari a
parte dai padri noi senza
genere la treccia le giocate si sta però
venti da sud dai quattro gallerie e
tritatelo deliziatevi ghiacciate giu
divertenti cliccate su quella che
preferite e buona